山田孝之さんを一生懸命止める初めに好き
だから僕も必須ですおじちゃん肇社長です
後ろや畑ですはいというわけでなんと山田
孝之さんが3年のうちに遊びにきて
くださいましたはい
だけで昨日ほんと1まとまって一緒にお酒
を飲んだりしたです
今日は残念普通意識
るー打つわけじゃないですけど見て回ると
いうか
全部白砂会式の暗かったそうで見るなよ
崩れるん
大阪中河内の心配をしてくれてるそこの
ことはないかと思っできる入れ new
冷蔵庫でいいんですかそんなことをして
いただいたところ
いきましょう
英語禁止ねっ
なにいろい
軽い軽い
6前回の0ゼロですけど言えばくださって
くださるなっているところ厳しかったので
極刑を喋ったら5分
ています2良いなぁさーん
ウェイバーちゃんのおへや曲がり始め
ましょうか熱いバーサー
カー
[音楽]
んドア
def
よぞかお前
[音楽]
ありがとう違うしてしまいましたよかった
です僕が裏にあります元欄にはなんですよ
ねやっぱり
ですがもうみんなじゃなくて存在
んでしょっます思います
伊奈町徳さあ面白さっていうか持ったら
いいじゃな
雨に戻っ選んだみたいなのがありますよ
じゃああー
宜しくお願いします
ああああああん
[音楽]
dare
それください上にベランダからぬ
はぁ早坂さんに買いに屋外があるのです
けど
僕が言うことにこうなるよねそうですね
言えることを押すがお手伝いしを友人に
対しています松尾あたりををっせるとこう
いう言葉を聞いたんですよ音が屋外になり
ますこういうのをね結構らもうちょっと
日々が来てるでしょ
そうなんですよ外だと仕方ないから
ちゃんテールしていけないですよですねー
ご覧
を入れてるぞ
取れたちゃんと締めてあげないとっ
こんなに座り悪いん
テンって転ぶ心配もないよね嘘ですね基本
的には丈夫だんですよねこれ月8日
パターンという危機んだけどバターなり
ましたあっあーってどうぞ
前にはいきましょうか前にははいっ
かやばいな
その間にこんなことになってたらそっちへ
ですしたのこういうところがあっている
はいはいこれ
でますねっ
カレーナンボっ
か使っている
危ないからさぁ声はちゃんといわしさんに
お任せしたねー
あっこれん
攻略法
俳優なんです
確かにこれから
支払い
もう限定で絶対によく通っているあっちっ
いるの思う
外は困難です中身はぜひです
[音楽]
[拍手]
ええええええ
重さ
オーシャンビュー入りました
おっしゃっていて
mar
何ん
2階ですねうん
一応
分
やっほー
ここは台所になりますが欲しいね石の建造
物なのでん
ちょっと無機質な感じでください
いつもああねー
[音楽]
皆さん
動画配信者は配役
挑戦していますよねそう選手はちょっと
大食いとかもよくってよね大きい
両県でますねらー皆さんの再生じゃね
入団した頃に来るなこれ
救世にやってるよちょこちょこやります
ちょっとちょっとキャラもできるぞ
4を入れます4位
を開始
[音楽]
[拍手]
今回いきましょう格好入って
ame
によっているのと再三
ああ
53回に行っておりますはい
俺があの自動で草履するお部屋なんです
けど部屋はいあ釣行記あ省抗議でそこん
だろうねもう来たときからそうしたわけで
そうなんだ本当に直してもらってからオス
がべしだな
けど早く服下がったんいやいい骨でやった
から無茶きれい作っ
はい変だよこれ
装甲騎
んだぞ部品取るが結構レアというの
はぁ伝統かそうですね運ぶためにはこれ
早く普及しないと思うんですね
ここ進出ではいはいお前がよく泊まりに
来るねー
[音楽]
まずがとうございます
は観覧のティッシュとかさ
たくないですよね
ちゃんと分
[音楽]
の人数はバイト出ることがあるということ
で多いとキャストでございますなんか
合宿所みたいであるでも術じゃないんだっ
たらこういうパターンだよ見なさいよそう
ですねただてどんな服しちゃう
もうねぇ
館放火はなくなったえっそうだけど
たくさんある日本にたくさんある緑の
あの家族のミドルだとっ
[拍手]
家族の願いです家族店緑白
ここでしょ
家族ミスああああ飼い主は24時間はい
はいはい便利ナビてるって所そうするあ
そうなんですね
時間をかけなくなってきましたね年生で
すってでもカッコイイのは分
必要なにもたとかだろう
そしてこちらの部屋が24時間やってる
便利の店を
回市民
[音楽]
動かすとか日用品も快晴正けど所いいわ
立金井にも危惧させてもらおうという
改善
うんん
の面も好きでたがるん
めっちゃいいですねっ
でもても折れそう
ですよねー
そうですね海鮮改善52年あの南米の赤
いい
液体の
辛いやつああ
なんかなどちょっ
スコスコスコって書けるやつ
はいはいもんかけて面白いですねあとは
ゆず7まあ美味しそう
やるんですって食べないかな
ピアノねはい
いい
busaiku
仕事場をして使かってね4回はもう意地は
家族が x 軸のかなとか思っている
コスメが
幹事長がの
このするべきうん形状年収部屋と言うか
そんな不安に付ける b 中徹がある
par ん
して遊べるん
dareブーブーを知っ
指数いてもあれは
し投げれば
したこれぞよね僕は方変われないよねまあ
でももうちょうどいいじゃない寝室として
進出
ここを歩いてはいる
このいでだねそうですね
この子を入れるかなーっ
衣装とか活用したいようだよねー
結果これがあるのになぜあそこにあんな床
に
9 o 型
+こっちの方がいい
いればと思うでしょそうです2人3人
ていませんここにするって言うよ確かに8
つの妖怪メダル取りたい
脳もあったした空調問題があったですね
遊ぶかいう
me
ギリだったとなるから
を上げていました
あとは物品の景色見ながら
とてもいいねぇよ
なんか調査
実感の3億乗って全然疲れてないとが優先
しちゃってますねーもん
大事だけれどもバランス奏しをバランス
そうですね
みたいまぁそこの
恋人ホラー
石投げていっ
ain
すっぺーなぁ
て上抜けです
言ってるのはいいねぇ
数巻
なんか
でも僕も山田さんにお会いできただけで
幸せな求人募集からそれがまずい
おじさんという家の中をプロップ
レッツ4番です
あって高校は使ってないです
大変めぐ見える海見える
[音楽]
富士山も見える
おじさん new
富士山見えるの3ds 3ds ll 三重
me
自分で言って女の母校プロ犯人からお酒か
もが僕の夢ですねじゃあそのためにね
持っておきたいですよねこれもあるしそう
ですね水分散
水分散がだ
hype 一応こんな感じですね準備かえ
ん
[音楽]
結果ありがとうございます
なぜサルーンで着付けを付けて下さい
ザッパした人こんな感じですね今日はもう
ほんとねやることだけですねただ一番の
問題はあなたがちょっと大きいて全体を見
ているところですまずこの部屋くれって
やっぱり個ずつやっておけばどんどんでき
ていくカッっともう細かいところはねはい
ティ書きっぱなしあげましょうえっと
終わってるよねー
いやー
ちり紙はとメタボ20 s クールタイム
墓もアップれる前にしてるってパイ結構
細かいところからやってみましょうはい
わかりましたとりあえず
いわーそうですね1番目2 p 文でも
最初にあるやる来たん気がするけどなぁ
までもに今こそも震度がもっと必要よ
アクシスはちゃんも速度オーナーそうです
よね様でもとりあえずでやりましょうには
やりましょう一人じゃないんですよねそう
ね協力者って言っていくしかないなぁ
ok
水
さぁづん
whちょっと風呂がある
nor re ん
ああああああ
すごい
めちゃ種を包んだ方が良かっ
風ません
が寒いっ
大変ライフスタイルまた戦争ですね
ちょっとセヨン0
おはようございますよ
true バッグトレイを治療してたら
品
今後かけません
いやーきれいにするアーサー王で絶品です
あっはいどうかはいよろしくお願います
けどね
出張記に仕事を通っていません
よろしくお願いますほしい
ません
ピエロ持ってるもん的にぶっ壊されるんだ
けどええええ
そんなんですよね
[音楽]
お前ません
えっ
持っていません
ああああああ
[音楽]
ん
持った
いろいろ背負った
ダイヤいますけどねつボルトせません
no する恐れ
ん
よかったブーブー
考えば聞いたことないけど
k カツ
でしょうっ
やばーい
伝えていました
声が濃い濃いため声が聞こえました
どうしているなおせんは大丈夫ですよ
次のポイントでありません
あっはぁ
ああああああ
シェルがあってきていますよねあっ聞こえ
ません
わー
ラピアさに反してないん
ありがとうございます
八卦とある
[音楽]
ウッド用ヘッドやマイクしていません考え
て太郎
ん
ってまた同じようになっちゃえば大丈夫な
いっ
とんとんみたよを
手をやりましたん
[ __ ]に触れて入るぞ
[音楽]
ん
me
皆様草むしり本当にありがとうございまし
た
ございましたお仕えしましたーー
こんな感じでヘアもう一つ一つやっていい
ですよそうですね
参考になっており今後
よしていただきたいですねおはようござい
ます本当に
誰ですかうん
夏をもうちょっとこう ji 2ちょっと
人手が必要だから集めてうって言ったんで
ちょっと皆さんのことをわかってないん
ですよぱから今僕たちが一緒に案件
here はじめしゃちょーかーさーん
この方程置き餌にしたいって申し訳あ4 k
それありがたいです本当時に作動油
方が高まり何ですか今回
静岡県三島市ですね
また孝之さんがプロデューサーを務められ
ていらっしゃいます
ミラーライアー film project
はいはんぺん入っんオウムに貼っ作品
シーズン3あっ3号
実は6月にですそうでしょ白いれてそれを
伝えしました
我々あの三島
ニール全く生徒とチラ見しまであの映像
制作会社を受けた方誰もが映画おく
そんな時代学生としまう2位我々で映画を
作る挑戦をしよう
短編映画作りに挑戦しているはいメンバー
を言われたし
チームなのに疲れ
た
私ねほんと社長ね私は方ですねところな
プライベートなの
てね本当に関西いっぱいですもうそんなて
際に来てくれた方々ん穴4倍てました
アーマーそうですね
英語禁止みたいな感じで歌ってた動きんし
て誰が言い出しました
というわけですねそのルールのもとにそう
ですねしバカせてもらったはいああ
ブームなんだけどけどやってい
映画を作り雨が良かった編パンが
さ無視してくれて
日付対馬軽いっていう
をちょっとと桜
イメージは良くないってこと申し訳ない
ことをしたなとは思ってはいませんだって
前も居るしたから始めチャンネル登録して
持ったもうある以降だってはじめたちは
映像協会のヒーローですかヘル政府ですか
ちょっとここでイメージせっかく上がった
のを下げるのはちょっと俺もとしても夫婦
だなと思う
僕もそうですねねはいそうだよね何個
なんかね
叶えてあげたらどうですかああなるほど
なるほど映画ってまあ一全て表現もそう
ですけど
作って終わりじゃないですかねやっぱりお
客さんに届けていろんな人たちの心を
動かしたいという気持ちがあるわけですよ
言葉では伝えられないことも映像2つさえ
方してるんですよね今日もね映像生産して
そう見てもらって価値が生まれる部分も
あると思うんで勇気づけたいみたいな
jal あります有馬されますコツ我々雨
人間も一緒なんですよ
肇社長はねもどって1000万人こういう
登録者木て大勢の人に見てもらえるから
けど
我はねまだまだ
プロジェクト自体も知らない人いっぱい
いるのでそれっ
大勲章見てもらいたいですね
はいうん北の空同じですね
どうやったらとか
僕わけです足今回分
皆さんだよはいうんなんかこうこれ
と思いますじゃねぇ見てちゃんと見ます
ちょっとフックさのシーンをしてくれた
わけですしなんかありますけどどうして
どうしてに出来ることがあればあっなんか
はいいろんな方に見に来てもらえてるん
ですよねまぁでもやっぱり皆さん学生さん
ですよね映画見るってすごく言いの時間
ですまあそうですねっとはやっぱりこのみ
さん8なことを学びながらアルバイトし
たいとかして結構きつめだから麻生せます
よね
ただの決して細野映画みなさんレベルかつ
安くはないっすよねねえちゃんとだから子
情報を入れて何を見に行くかって選ぶわけ
ですよねってもなんかそういったところで
もねこのミラーや pm ずうずう
プロジェクトですかというやつ安いんです
けども ok ここ
はいこれ見に行くって言うなんかそこでも
白なんじゃないかって言う
発見に行くと言う
プロジェクタらしいんですよ
僕はするエーーーガーー
みるときてこの映画館行ってー
必要なものがありますよ
何かがないと責任ですけどあー
つけっ
ととかですかああそうですね
1800なんですよあ1800入ってきて
くれるかんでさぁ結果空きついけど社長
通すかボス1,800円もちろんねはい
大変ですよか泣かせたそうですよねご本人
たちもを家族兄弟とか東急請求かはい周り
はいる安く見てもらっていいですよね
見てもらいたい
はいです
なることということはそれをちょっと社長
に入って手伝ってもらえたらなと思います
よねえんだろう選んだぞ
以前の手伝いますよもちろんもう私の
シャワー
[音楽]
[拍手]
を載せておきました頑張って入ったらもう
ご友人ご家族みなさんの役もそうですし
今回初監督した人とかもいっぱいいます
そのクリエイターた順列をはじめ社長が皆
さんに届けてくれると今ここで言ってくれ
ました
具体的に何をすればいいか等でまたまた
って全然前がそれはもうの大丈夫ですよ
こちら任せください
本文何ですか僕前回あの前回の話青いたい
から私監督で今回かここですねこれ南33
突起では風んおおぉ
見てもありですね多くの人にんん皆さんの
作ったものとかじゃあ
飯島社長ありがとうございますはぁ
たんだ一つ見てみればない
まあ今見ますか一変するまあ包丁でしょ
なんかそんなだというお言葉を頂けたら象
瀬メッセありがとうって言ってるんだけど
[拍手]
voodoo
ブーバしま
[音楽]
うー
doぷっちょ